>> Joe: YEAH, YEAH.
A TURNOVER.
>> Sam: GOODROW GOODROW HAS SHO
THE MESSAGE TO THE
WILSON DEALERS.
IT IS FOURTH IN THE
TROUBA.
PLAYJENSEN.
BACK FROM TROUBA.ATES THAT RIGL.
IN THE MIDDLE.
DOWN   GAME.T SURE WHERE IT WAS
THAT.COLUMBUS.
ZIBANEJAD.
THE SITTING BACK IN
THE NET.
WHEN THE TURNOVER HAHAD BY NEME.
HE SCORES!
AND THE CAPS COM
WHEN THE INITIAL SHOT GOES H RO
TO MOVE ITIT
DONATION
THIRD PERIOD.
COLUMBUS HAS SCORED TO MAKE IT
?
ONE PASS, TWO, THREE, NOW
LAFRENIERE SCORES!O STSTTHERE'S.
A
PITTSBURGH PENGUINS IN THE FIRST
ROUND.
TOGETHER.
GOOD TOUCH PASSES BY THE WITH I.
KAKKO SENDS IT ON GOAL.
JOHN CARLSON HEADS UP ICE.E. LE.
TOM WILSON TRYING TO TIE IT.
KUZNETSOV HAS IT.
ROONEY IS ON RIGHT THERE.
ALL I KNOW, KUZNETSOV.
THAT WAS A CHEAPMILLER.
EXCUSE ME, NEMETH. SHOT